this first even led to the revered
father of the early church origin to
castrate himself oh my
oh my like what what did you think when
you were like I need to show Pearl this
today like what am I gonna do with this
information hey Mom Dad did you know
that people voluntarily chopped their
dicks off just like they do today what
up guys welcome to the judge pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to my
reaction series of today King has given
me a you know short YouTube video called
forgotten history about [__] uh that's
the title right
um before I start don't forget to like
the video subscribe and if you have
anything you want me to react to send it
to my Instagram just pearly things once
what is eunuch
the eunuch it's Unix basically the guys
that they cut off their things so that
they can't reproduce oh it's like the
slaves didn't they do that in the Middle
East
well I don't know but like basically I
heard in the Middle East that that was
like the most brutal slavery it was like
they had to walk across this desert and
half of them died and then when they got
there they got their balls chopped
basically so that they can't reproduce
the fine as someone usually a man whose
testes and sometimes also penis and
scrotum have been destroyed or removed
this leads to sterility depending on the
stage of Life at which it is done
various degrees of impotence and loss of
libido may occur free pubertal
castration causes a unicoid build which
causes the person to be tall have broad
hips narrow shoulders and breasts like
that of a woman secondary sexual
characteristics effects such as small
genitals lack of beard and an unbroken
voice may also occur castration after
puberty does not lead to degeneration of
secondary sexual characteristics the
build remains unchanged the reduction of
sexual activity is unpredictable
although sterile castrate May remain
potent for a year or longer some even
retain libido throughout their lives
there is a reduction in aggression but
other abnormalities of the psyche are
usually representative of a
psychological reaction to force
castration the accompanying humiliation
and rejection by the community in
addition to the effects of hormonal
deprivation I think if I was castrated I
would just kill myself I'm serious
that'd be like a horrible life to live I
can't even and now now the guy's getting
like boobs and oh my gosh so where were
the eunuchs prevalent in ancient times
against whom these procedures taken upon
let's try and find out hello I'm Mike
droberg Marine Corps veteran and
filmmaker we will try to answer these
questions on today's episode of
Forgotten history
[Music]
foreign
Antiquity eunuchs were mostly employed
in the Middle East and in China with two
main functions guards and servants and
harems or other woman's quarters and as
chamberlains the Kings Assyrians are
credited with creating eunuchs for
government service because it was
believed that since they could not have
any Offspring they would not attempt to
overthrow the ruler create their own
hereditary Dynasty later the Assyrians
created eunuchs for ritual religious
purposes streets of kubaba goddess of
fertility voluntarily became Unix at the
altar so that their goddess would
provide them a plentiful Harvest to
prevent droughts bring prosperity to
their people eunuchs were considered the
most suitable guards of the many wives
or concubines a ruler may have in this
Palace the Unix confidential position in
the harems frequently enabled them to
exercise an important influence over
their Royal Masters and even to raise
themselves to stations of great trust
and power some Rose to become bodyguards
confidential advisors even ministers
generals and Admirals most eunuchs
underwent castration as a condition of
their employment though others were
castrated as punishment or after had
been sold into slavery eunuch's
functioned as political advisors to the
Emperors of China as early as the ciao
from 1122 221 BC and continued as such
under the Han Tang Ming it sounds so
crazy this shows just how much harder
men really had it like this [__] did not
happen to women not really as far as I
know I mean someone in the comments can
correct me if I'm wrong but whenever
there's something horrible that happens
it always happens to men more than women
like when the Titanic sank most of the
women survived on that ship and they're
like you know what sorry guys and they
literally had like so if any guy tried
to get on the lifeboats get his ass shot
and here I mean I understand the thought
process because how many times have you
heard about like the rich wife [__]
the pool boy they're saying like to
guard the harems okay which is kind of
crazy that guys will be employed by one
man and then screw is what persisting
almost until the end of the Imperial
regime at times Palace eunuchs became
more powerful than the emperor
effectively rule China Unix were used as
Court advisors and officials in Persia
under recommended from 559 to 330 BC the
Roman emperors Claudius Nero and Titus
also employed Unix after Nero's wife
papaya Sabina died in 65 A.D supposedly
a childbirth although it was later
rumored Nero kicked her to death later
that following year he married spores
young slave boy which he had castrated
during their marriage Nero had spores
appear in public as his wife wearing the
regalia that was customary for Roman
emperors among other forms of addressed
spores was termed lady empress and
mistress Tony is quotes one Roman lived
around this time who remarked the world
would have been better off Nero's father
had married someone more like the
castrated boy going forward so he said
that he'd be better off if he married
someone more like the castrated boy all
the Western Roman Empire and the Eastern
Empire in Constantinople many of the
Patriarchs during the Byzantine times
for example Justinian the first had
eunuch bodyguard and even many of the
legendary janissary especially in our
men at the first and Murad the first and
Murad the second were eunuchs who were
in political positions political eunuchs
also flours in the centers of Muslim
power after ad750 as a class eunuch
advisors only disappeared with the end
of the Ottoman Empire early 20th century
although not a form of eunuchism in
terms of the definition above voluntary
abstention from sexual activity played a
strong role among the early father
giving her eyes in due course the
establishment of celibacy and the
monastic religious orders relationship
was perceived between eunuchism the
voluntary abstention from sexual
activity or dedication to God the
interpretation of the Gospel of Matthew
1912 for there are eunuchs were born
that way who have been made eunuchs by
others there are those who choose to
live like eunuchs for the sake of the
Kingdom of Heaven one who can't accept
this this first even led to the revered
father of the early church origin
castrate himself an act which oh my
self-inflicted wow
it's been happening for a long time did
you show me like what what did you think
when you were like I need to show Pearl
this today I need to expand your horizon
to what like what am I gonna do with
this information hey Mom Dad did you
know that people voluntarily chop their
dicks off just like they do today well
it's greater Insight bitterly regretted
Clement of Alexandria recommended the
virtues of self-discipline and the
avoidance of indulgences but warned that
celibacy was worthless unless undertaken
in the love of Christ various fanatical
Christian sects such as the Arabian
Galatians mannequins in the figurine
mountainous accepted self-castration as
a part of their religious practice
church leaders such as Cassian
entitation even denounce sexual
intercourse as diabolical oh Gregory the
seventh want to impose celibacy upon all
priests and monks while monks were so
ordained the priests were spared until
the second lateran Council in 1139 that
made celibacy mandatory for all Catholic
clergy Italian practice of castrating
boy I didn't know our priests weren't
always selling in order to train them as
a adult soprano singers was ended by
Pope Leo the 13th in 1878. so throughout
history eunuchs were usually forced they
the Catholics castrated the boy please
I'm Catholic guys we gotta stop with
this weird [__] we uh Hey sex
reassignment surgeries are on the rise a
number of procedures including the
removal and construction of external
genitalia increased nearly fourfold from
two thousand thousand fourteen according
to the study published in the Journal of
JMA however what is not commonly known
that complications from genital
surgeries are common California study
found that a quarter of the 869
vaginoplasty patients had a surgical
complications so severe that they had to
be hospitalized again furthermore Joseph
backholm president of the family policy
Institute of Washington said there is no
conclusive evidence that these
procedures lead to beneficial outcomes
transgender patients people who go
through gender masks
disproportionate I interviewed someone
that did it and this person literally
cannot pee like they have to pee out of
like a catheter for the rest of their
life and basically most of the people
that get this stuff are literally
autistic they just tell autistic people
and then they don't show them what like
the vagina and like dick it's gonna look
like they don't show them like real
pictures so it looks completely
different I was scrolling on Twitter one
day and there was just like a fake
vagina and dick on my timeline they're
literally just running experiments on
these people man because what what's
what what's the easiest way to get
voluntary Lab Rats convince them that
what they're doing makes sense and then
all of them will just keep flooding in
and paying for their own yeah for
themselves to be used as experiment
that's crazy yeah well it made me so sad
when he was telling me they were mostly
autistic so I just think that's like
like you're not really like fair I mean
if you if you look at all these like um
Pride
um yeah they're weird yeah all these
Pride what's it called matches and stuff
even the way they go about their uh
what's it called their protesting very
abnormal like the way they just scream
and shout yeah it's not normal yeah
levels of stress anxiety and suicidality
Mr back home said he calls into question
whether rushing into this actually help
scarier still thousands of youths are
lining up for gender affirming care
parents must make decisions about
life-altering treatment that have little
scientific evidence their long-term
safety and effort while also the number
of gender clinics treating children in
the United States has grown from zero to
more than 100 in the past 15 years
puberty blockers and sex hormones do not
have the U.S Food and Drug
Administration approval for children's
gender no clinical trials have
established their safety for such
off-label use the Drug's long-term
affects sexual function remained
uncleared in 2016 the FDA ordered makers
of puberty blockers to add a warning
about psychiatric problems to the drugs
label after the agency received several
reports of Suicidal Thoughts in children
who were taken more broadly no
large-scale Studies have tracked people
who've received relief well and that's
the thing I don't think we really know
the downstream effects of all of these
surgeries birth control like all this
[__] we're doing is new you know I have
a nanny that she got a shot that they I
remember they recommended it it was
something with it was supposed to
prevent like a certain STD or something
and I remember they asked me if I wanted
the same one and I said no because it's
like they just do it when you get your
checkup or whatever yeah my my nanny
ended up um getting infertile because of
it and she's like 40 and she she got
married and she just
um it's actually really sad because she
was one of my favorite nannies like she
would have been such a good mom like and
literally
um because of this shot like it made her
infertile though you know um I think
there's a lot of stuff we don't really
know you know I I think a lot of women
are going to have effects from like
birth control too because like how do
you really know all the side effects of
it and especially there were like
waiting longer and longer to have kids
so it's like what is turning off your
fertility for a decade
um you know even the ones that have used
it and then eventually have kids we
still don't even know the effects it
will have on the kids as well yeah or
even with like daycare like they're
showing
um like the side effects of like daycare
on kids because you know
um like it gives kids like attachment
issues because it's not good for them to
like switch or takers or whatever so at
daycare like especially when there's
rotating staff it's like not good
children to determine how many remain
satisfied with their treatment as they
age how many eventually regretted
transitioning same lack of clarity holds
true for the contentious issue of
de-transitioning I can't even lie I just
think I'm a bit two-sided on that one
though because where I grew up basically
raised in the community so it's like you
always around different people but I
just think it's mostly the fact that
there isn't actual culture in these
parts of the world that is where the
problem is because back then even if we
were being raised by so many other
people who are still being taught the
same things the same values you get but
now you don't even know what the daycare
person daycare person could be like some
person that believes in like
different things that have nothing to do
with what you would want them to learn
and stuff like that even us with like
the nannies because it would switch
every like two years roughly like one to
two years some of them are weird I I had
some really good ones I was really lucky
but yeah some of them are weird as hell
like one ended up being like like they
found out she was doing cam work
transition process current debate which
is being challenged in the courts are
the attempts by school teachers and
advisors discuss these options with
underage students without consulting the
parents so in conclusion we've gone from
an era of castration being forced upon
slaves now allowing the castration of
our children children under the age of
18 cannot get tattoos vote by Firearms
or purchase alcohol or cigarettes but
some people think they are capable
making these life-altering decisions
yeah and especially
again we believe anything but either way
I don't understand like I think anyone
over the age of like 22 even can see how
much you're thinking switches from when
you're a teenager to like when you're
older silly but you know thank you for
torturing me with that today you're
welcome
um guys like the video on your way out
subscribe to the channel and I'll talk
to you next time